السودان اعلنا والي ولايه جنوب دارفور
حامد التجاني هنود حاله الطوارئ بالولايه
وحضر التجوال داخل محليه بليله وكره
المحليه الواقعه قرب مدينه نيالا عاصمه
الولايه شهدت الشبكات قابليه بين مزارعين
ورعاه خلفت قتلى وجرحى واعلنت فيها نهايه
اهليه بولايه جنوب دارفور عن مقتل 10
اشخاص واصابه 30 فيها جماعه شنتها مليشيات
المسلحه على قرى الشرقيه الولايه
التي وقعت يوم الخميس والجمعه ادت الى حرق
15 قريه وتسرد ال 10 من قراهم والاهلي
وكميات من المحاصيل الزراعيه
وفي ايطالي ردود الافعال قال عضو مجلس
السياده طاهر حجر الذي يزور ولايه شمال
دارفور حاليا على الدوله عازمه على تحقيق
السلام ومحاربه الظواهر السلبيه عبر
انتشار القوه المشتركه لحمايه المدنيين في
دارفور
اتفاق سلامي جوبا تحقيقا للسلام
والاستقرار رغم التحديات التي تواجه بعض
بروضه لارض الواقع في السياق
وداعت حكومه الولايه والحكومه المركزيه
الى التحرك الفوري لحمايه المواطن من
العزه
الحركه ان هذا الهجوم لم يكن الاول بل ذكر
مرات عند في انحاء اقليم دار فور فور وقد
افلت من سمتهم المجرمين في كل المرات
السابقه من العقاب